so when you think about asset prices
themselves right we've obviously seen
tons of tech stocks sell off
significantly over the last few months
we've seen uh bitcoin go down 50 percent
uh we've seen a kind of cooling off
across a lot of these uh various aspects
of the market but we've also seen
berkshire hathaway hit an all-time high
and kind of a lot of the value type
stuff uh do well how do you look at the
impact of these fed decisions on the
actual asset prices across various
sectors
yeah so it's uh that's a great
phenomenal question that's uh it's the
high level finance question there so
i'll unpack and so you said a few things
that are really important um the types
of stocks that are outperforming the
types of assets that are doing well or
relatively well not everything's doing
well in absolute terms but relatively
well have been these sort of kind of
real economy stocks like banks and
energy stocks you know things that you
can physically touch and taste and and
hold on those types of stocks tend to be
less um influenced by the direction of
interest rates either short-term
interest rates or longer-term interest
rates and all the things that have been
sort of more correlated to longer-term
interest rates correlated to kind of
narratives around sort of future growth
prospects future prospects of adoption
anything that is sort of has a very uh
strong growth curve has really been hit
so that obviously includes bitcoin
includes a lot of tech stocks uh just
includes a lot of high beta higher beta
assets in general so um the fact that
we're seeing that rotation is suggestive
that the market is not ready to sort of
go um at this particular time in
juncture and go all the way down and
actually start the crash because
typically what you see is that whenever
the market rotates in what we call a pro
cyclical manner in a correction it
usually lends uh leads to a sort of
recovery you know that's a dip that you
generally want to be bought but you
don't want to buy the kinds of dips you
don't want to buy are when the market is
getting defensive i.e buying sort of
boring companies like utilities like
consumer staples like walmart and things
of that nature those are the kinds of
dips you don't want to buy so things are
fine for now but the the window for them
to not be fine it continues to shrink
so let's talk about the fed's impact on
individuals themselves right earlier
this year or i guess late last year a
couple months ago uh there was this
famous quote that jerome powell was
asked uh you know hey do you think the
fed is contributing to wealth inequality
and he was like well nobody's coming to
my office and told me that and we were
like i mean we had a field day like we
absolutely had a field day at the fact
that he said that we pulled up the
picture of the office we were like how
do you even get into that building like
the whole thing right
and so uh obviously i think that maybe
he misspoke let's give him the benefit
of the doubt there uh but
how much should we be blaming the
federal reserve or other types of
monetary and fiscal policy kind of over
uh sears on things like the wealth
inequality gap which is now at the kind
of widest range that it's ever been is
there a way to kind of quantify that or
should we actually go and kind of point
the finger at them or is that unfair no
no they're certainly in our opinion the
number one culprit now they're not the
only culprit um sort of you could sort
of i would point to sort of kind of two
big thing actually three big things that
have really catalyzed um this sort of
widening income dispersion and wealth
dispersion we've seen in in the u.s usa
and really throughout the global economy
because what i'm about to say is not
endemic to the u.s um one sort of
globalization um you know we've shipped
a lot of our jobs to sort of uh lower
cost producers namely china particularly
when china joined the wto back in i want
to say november 2001. in fact i remember
when i was a kid this must have been
when i was sixth or seventh grade um the
wto riots were a huge deal in seattle
from seattle and you know and needless
to say like you know 20 something years
later and you know 50 of our
manufacturing jobs having been offshored
i could see why that people were having
a riot back then um so that was a that
was kind of foreshadowing to where we
are today um but you kind of direct so
that was the number one globalization
and the kind of hollowing out of our our
manufacturing base in our middle class
uh number two uh i would argue obviously
the proliferation of technology you just
need less people to do stuff it's just a
lot easier for one person or a small
group of people to accomplish the things
that uh a lot more people have
historically had to uh you needed the
more manpower to get accomplished and
then lastly the fed uh i wouldn't say
last of the feds i think the fed is
probably the overwhelming driving force
here which is
the more you cut interest rates the more
likely it the more likely it is it
favors the existing players you know the
the existing players can sort of uh
raise debt very cheaply and build very
large moats around their businesses um
and and more importantly not only do
they build boats around the businesses
you know they can start acquiring other
businesses and doing things like that
and that acquisition's uh obviously you
tend to see less innovation you tend to
see less new uh business formation and
all the good stuff that comes along with
that so it's the economy itself just
becomes less dynamic
got it and so when you start to think
about like inflation how it impacts
various uh kind of uh cohorts of the
american population right i think it's
very clear that inflation made rich
richer and made poor poor uh in the
sense that a lot of the inflationary
goods uh especially the most severely
affected inflationary goods uh is a
large portion of monthly expenses for uh
the least fortunate or kind of the most
vulnerable in our society and so when
you start to think about this is this uh
one piece of like the positive side of
inflation coming down of this monetary
policy kind of tightening is that there
will be some relief for those folks that
are are the most vulnerable or are we uh
reading too much into it and actually
prices that went up they're not coming
back down and so maybe there's not an
increasingly worse situation but they're
pretty much in a bad situation and
they're stuck there because those prices
that went up aren't going to be brought
back down over time
yeah no so prices almost never go down
right deflation is a very rare
occurrence it only happens in recession
where you actually see prices go down
and not and even not all recessions have
actually seen the price overall price
level the price index level of cpi go
down what we're talking about when we
say the word inflation is not akin to
prices it's akin to the change in prices
and so right now on a year over year
basis per the most recent headline cpi
statistics the the amount of price
whatever you're paying for something has
gone up seven percent uh on a
year-over-year basis so for example if
you bought a bag of chips that cost a
dollar um in december of 2020 it now
costs a dollar seven uh dollar and seven
cents uh in december 2021 so that
doesn't seem like a big deal but the
reality is when you're living on a
budget and you're already living
paycheck to paycheck and you know the
you know when one costs go up you're
hopeful that you know another cost goes
down so that your overall living
situation um and quality of life doesn't
change but what happens with inflation
is that everything is going up all the
same time and it's going up faster than
your wages and so that over your overall
purchasing power and the quality of your
life goes down and i certainly
understand that better than most yeah
and so when you start to think also
about kind of the federal reserve one of
the things that um i always you know
kind of balance in my head is they have
official mandates and then they have
these unofficial things that people kind
of try to label or throw onto them so
the official mandates of stable prices
and maximum employment right and that's
their goal is how do we get to full
employment how do we get uh stable
prices uh for the last two years for the
most part they failed at those two
things now there have been these
external uh kind of uh reasons why and
uh people can debate all day long are we
heading the right direction wrong
direction whatever but it also seems
like the federal reserve is now being
asked whether it's by politicians by the
american public by the media et cetera
to start to weigh in on other issues as
well not just stable prices and full
employment so two examples that i'll use
is uh global warming or climate change
and racism right and so let's start
first with the global warming uh type
stuff which is we've seen multiple calls
both from politicians media and also the
american public of the federal reserve
should uh you know basically come out
publicly make a statement and commit to
actually addressing climate change or uh
global warming how do you think about
that type of stuff is that a distraction
for the federal reserve do they actually
have an ability to impact that stuff or
is this like classic virtue signaling of
those various groups just trying to
point a finger at oh nobody likes you
know central banks let's just blame it
on them
yeah well no i think it's a bug of the
overall system right the federal reserve
monetary authorities have no business
dealing with these types of issues the
issue is that we actually can't get
anything done in congress and so we punt
these big major societal issues these
big debates of our time onto the only
sort of you know policy making a board
uh that is not as hostage to the
election cycle right the supreme court's
got its own you know
it's busy doing its own thing so like
the fed is like all right well
you guys don't have to get elected you
deal with this and that's exactly what's
happening when it comes to global
warming um what was the other one it was
global warming and uh oh and and sort of
uh racism and things of that nature and
so the fed going back to uh the summer
of 2020 uh changed its mandate a little
bit amended it uh slightly to include
sort of maximum inclusive employment and
that and inclusive part means that hey
look we understand or based on our
analysis of our own mistakes in years
past and cycles past is that we always
sort of take the punch ball away from
the party too soon like right when the
black kids and hispanic kids show up
they take the punchbowl out of the party
and so the fed effectively changed its
mandate its inflation mandate to allow
for more black kids and hispanic kids
and people who have historically been
disaffected um or sort of sort of always
showed up to the party late in terms of
the economy getting wages all that other
stuff you know to to give them an
opportunity to get in and have some fun
um the reality is they sort of done they
did that at precisely the wrong time as
it relates to the fiscal policy agenda
the fiscal policy agenda basically said
hey no look we're going to give
everybody a bunch of money uh even
though the kind of the productive sector
of the economy the productive capacity
of not just our economy but the whole
global economy is actually reduced so we
created this gigantic supply and demand
imbalance at the same time the fed was
saying hey no look we want everybody to
come into the party and have a good time
and so the fact complicated manners with
respect to fiscal policy what they
should have been doing
you know a year ago there's a lot of
really smart people uh in and around the
fed former fed presidents and chairman
uh sort of uh my man from uh
new york fed i i'm blanking on his name
but he's been scaving them for like a
year now in terms of like hey look you
should be
taking the punch ball away if the fiscal
authority is put you know sort of uh
supplying more punch right imagine like
right you know like the fed the there's
like a bottle of jaeger and a bottle of
like grain and bottle of vodka and
they're all like just double fisted
pouring stuff into the into the punch
bowl and the punch bowl got so over full
on that it created a lot of these
inflation problems that we see today so
now effectively the powell jay powell
and the federal reserve now are saying
hey look we realize we got to take this
punch bowl away now and it's becoming an
issue for markets but the problem the
bigger issue and i think we'll talk
about this in a few months as we
progress throughout the year but the
bigger issue is now they're both taking
it away
and that's going to become a big problem
for markets